my story is confusing some guys like
guys some guys like girls some guys like
both I'm not even sure what I like I
cannot tell you how much I love love
Victor and it's so exciting that it's
debuting in June in Pride Month how are
you feeling right now honestly over the
moon I'm really excited and it means the
world to me that you had you seen love
Simon before you were cast as Victor
tell me about your backstory a little
bit I saw the love Simon movie with like
a few of my friends and I literally
walked out there being like knit I can
not wait to be part of a project like
this because they just like affected me
so deeply you know I was like this is a
great movie and then literally here we
are knows before you started filming had
you heard from Simon himself Nick
Robinson we actually spoke at the end of
filming instead of rather than in the
beginning because like we shot our scene
for like we shot a scene together but we
filmed it in New York when we did that
was like our last day of shooting it was
like kind of symbolic in a way I feel
like how would you describe Victor I
feel like everyone is gonna fall in love
with him your portrayal is so endearing
what do you want fans to know about him
before they tune in I definitely want
them to know that Victor is outgoing and
kind and also kind of like a fixer you
know he always like puts other people's
issues over his own but also in the same
token you know this is like a story
about his journey of self-discovery and
it's also kind of an exploration of
getting to know his family the Salazar
family they're such a great group and
you get to see so many different themes
throughout these first 10 episodes why
do you think it's important that we're
getting to see Victor's journey along
with his family is what do you think
we're exploring that we weren't able to
with love Simon well I think it's more
like a deep dive on a different kind of
experience you know Victor is of a
different economical class
he's also of a different ethnicity his
family is in a different like has a
different political views like slash
beliefs like they're more conservative
Simon's family family was more liberal
so there's a lot of different
contrasting things that
offer a different perspective and what
does it mean for you to be a Latino lead
of this amazing groundbreaking TV series
it's an honor
honestly again like a different
perspective and it gives people a chance
to see you know to see the struggle
through a different lens and I think
that that's the most important part
especially right now because you know
perspective is everything and we need to
offer as much perspective as possible as
possible that people can learn your
family must be so proud
thank you you know they are actually my
mom cried when the teaser came out like
this really overtly sexual teaser she
was crying her eyes out so hilarious as
you were stepping into Victor's shoes
more throughout the season what did you
find to be the most rewarding part for
you probably the most rewarding part
hasn't really come yet you know I can't
wait to see how much this show affects
other people's lives and know I know
it's changed my life so much and I hope
it has that kind of effect on other
people he's really coming to terms with
himself in first season he's trying to
figure out does he like guys does he
like girls and he develops a really
close friendship and relationship with
this bright girl named Mia for the fans
out there who are gonna be tuning in
being like I thought I was watching a
gay love story what do you want to tell
them about what Victor's going through
in this first season it says it
literally in the first episode is that
you know no story is like one in the
same and I feel like the thing that's
different about Victor is that he's not
sure about his sexuality
he's questioning it in so because of
that that doesn't mean that he's not gay
or he's not straight or he's not bi it
just means that he's figuring out where
he lies and I think that you know every
story is completely different and I
think it's so great that we can actually
be able to step into his shoes and watch
his journey and experience this and I
think it's gonna really help people kind
of empathize with what so many people in
the gay community go through on a daily
basis we are in a time where it's like
we have so many people are accepted but
also so many people are on the complete
opposite spectrum of that and we need to
be working to get everyone to be
accepted just for who they are
because it doesn't really matter what
your sexuality is or any of that what
you're you know how you identify
yourself as a person you just need to be
yourself authentically I think that's
the most important thing is love Victor
a spinoff a continuation series a reboot
break it down for me and then do you
think that fans need to have watched
love Simon before they tuned in
it is definitely like a spinoff of the
movie but I think the writers did it in
such a way where you don't necessarily
need to watch the movie to you know
watch love Victor and enjoy it but if
you haven't watched the movie you should
be watching it like it's it's an amazing
movie it's definitely worth the watch
but if you haven't watched it today you
can still watch live pictures I was
really excited to see that in the loved
after pilot they set it up so
beautifully that it was a really organic
explanation of who Simon was what life
is like at Creek wood high and just kind
of a great introduction for Victor into
this world I think you're gonna enjoy a
lot more like the subtle cues because
there's some like little throwbacks to
the show or to movie here and there and
I think that you'll enjoy that a lot
more if you have watched the movie or
else I might just like go over your head
but still look I think you could still
watch it 16 will be the year I finally
figure out what I want
Victor
[Music]